ومن هناك تنضم الينا نجوان صبري
نعم يعني صخب في داخل الكنيسه
واحتجاجات خارجه ايضا على هذه الحكومه
التي توصف بانها يمينيه متطرفه للاكثر
تطرفا ربما في تاريخ اسرائيل كما يقولوا
المحتج
[موسيقى]
نجوان
واضح هل تسمعني
ولكن عموما كنت اسالك عن
الاحتجاجات الموجوده خارج الكنيسه
نعم بالفعل مع بدا هذه الجلسه وخطاب
بنيامين نتنياهو رئيس الحكومه الجديده وصل
الى هنا قباله مقر الكنيسه مئات
الاسرائيليين من فئات مختلفه للاحتجاج على
تشكيل هذه الحكومه التي يصفونها بالاكثر
تطرفا من النواحي عده من النواحي السياسيه
من النواحي الدينيه وايضا اجتماعيه هناك
عده جهات ومؤسسات تشارك في هذه المظاهره
منها من يعارض محاولات اقصاء المراه
والفصل بين الرجل والمراه ضمن تصريحات
سابقه لاعضاء الحكومه الجدد من الاحزاب
الدينيه
المتزمته وايضا احزاب الصهيونيه الدينيه
التي يرتكز نتنياهو عليها في حكومته
الجديده
اتمنى يعارض
التوجهات السياسيه لهذه الحكومه ويقولون
بانهم غير ملزمون بحروب اخرى تشان بسبب
هذه الحكومه
والضد العنصريه وايضا ضد تمسك نتنياهو
بالسلطه من اجل انقاذ نفسه من المحاكمه
همم محاكمته في تهم الفساد التي يتهم
ويحاكم عليها همم
الان اسمع الى خطاب نستمع الى خطاب نتنياه
وقد بداؤه بالحديث عن المهمه الاولى لهذه
الحكومه والتي قال بانها احباط قيام ايران
بامتلاك سلاح نووي هذا ما عمل عليه وبنى
استراتيجياته عليه نتنياه لسنوات عده منذ
ان اصبح رئيسا للحكومه في الفتره الاولى
نتحدث عن حكومه سادسه برئاسه نتنياهو رغم
انه ان يعرض نفسه بانه الاقوى اذا انه
تمكن من تشكيل هذه الحكومه وهو صاحب اطول
ولايه في هذا المنصب منذ اقامه اسرائيل
الا انه يوصف ايضا بانه يشكل هذه الحكومه
هذه المره من منطلق ضعف ويتهم من قبل
المعارضه الاسرائيليه ومن جهات اخرى بانه
ردخ
لمطالب وشروط الاحزاب الاخرى التي تشاركه
في هذا الائتلاف على راسها مثلا ما حدده
له لتمار بني كبير المتطرف احد زعماء
احزاب الصهيونيه الدينيه الذي سمى القانون
سنه الكنيست قانونا خاصا به من اجل توسيع
صلاحياته في وزاره الامن القومه هي وزاره
الشرطه ووزاره الامن الداخلي لكنها لكنها
غير اسم هذه الوزاره وطلبه ان ان تكون
قوات حرس الح التابعه للشرطه الاسرائيليه
تحت سيادته بالاضافه الى اجزاء اخرى من
صلاحيات الشرطه نقلت له بموجب هذا القانون
هذا بالاضافه الى تشريعات وتعديلات
قانونيه اخرى تم سمنها خلال الاسبوع
الاخير فقط
لاداحه قيام هذه الحكومه منها قانون يتيح
لارياء درعي زعيم حركه شمس ان يصبح وزيرا
رغم ادانته بمخالفات جنائيه ماليه هذا
بالاضافه الى تعيين مثل ال اسمه تريتش
ايضا زعيم اخر في حزب الصهيونيه الدينيه
كوزير اضافي في وزاره الدفاع مع صلاحيات
واسعه في الاداره المدنيه
التي تنصق عمليات الاحتلال للحكومه
الاسرائيليه في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
المحتله تغييرات كثيره وهناك قوانين اخرى
مدرجه على اجنده هذه الحكومه وفقا
الاتفاقيات الائتلافيه تثير جدلا واسعا
ايه لدى شرائح في المجتمع الاسرائيلي يبدو
بان هذا المجتمع الاسرائيلي الذي انتخب
هذه الحكومه بدا يصحو اكثر بعد التصريحات
التي بدا اعضاء في هذا الائتلاف يدلون بها
مباشره بعد انتخابهم نتحدث عن تصريحات
تتعلق بالعنصريه ان يتم تشريع قانون
وتغيير قانون اساس في اسرائيل يمنع
العنصريه ولكن هناك مطالب لهذه الاحزاب
بتغييره والكثير الكثير عثمان من هذه
القوانين ويبدو باننا مقبلون على فتره
اكثر شراسه وتطرفا في اسرائيل
شكرا جزيلا لك نجوان السمري من امام
الكنيسه الاسرائيلي